as [ __ ] ass has bad words hey hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
birthdays and birthday gifts Ryan we're
gonna talk about gifting experiences
we're gonna talk about our favorite
consumables to give as a gift yeah man
and we're gonna talk about when it's
appropriate to give physical gifts you
know it was Becca's birthday this past
week where'd you get her well it was
fast
I asked Ella in the morning like we all
woke up we let her sleep in there was a
that's a birthday gift right got pots
and pans overhead dumping water on her
waking her up Ella kind of is but that's
her that's her mo thankfully Ella sleeps
in too but I asked Ella in the morning I
said hey how old your mom today cuz
she's like hey it's mom's birthday I'm
like I know let's let her sleep a little
bit longer
I said how old's your mom today she goes
I don't know ask Siri before we dive
into these questions I want and before
we talk about the our birthday
experience this past week I want a gift
from our audience Ryan I'm asking them
for a gift okay I feel it's polite
sometimes to let people know what you
want right but you already have enough
tight clips yeah I have enough zero
the thing that I want to ask for and we
usually ask for this once or twice a
year it's like it's like a birthday gift
and a Christmas gift kind of thing
doesn't if your birthday birthday is on
Christmas do you think that would have
been like simultaneously awful and great
as a kid I mean as a Jehovah's Witness
it didn't matter yeah you didn't have
gifts all right it might have been
better because it was only one day that
I couldn't celebrate it was multiple
days a year yeah and so the gift I'm
asking for is we want to review from
from you all we only asked us once or
twice a year in fact last year we didn't
ever we didn't ask a single time I don't
think in 2018 and the reason this is
important is twofold one is I think most
of us suck at leaving reviews on stuff
now last year I was my new year's
resolution I resolved to review more
and that went really well for about nine
months and then all of a sudden I fell
back into my old patterns of not
participating in the review process well
the only time I want to leave a review
mostly like 90% of the time it's when I
have a really bad experience right but
when you have a really good experience
that's it you should be motivated right
yeah and so it is about 10 percent of
the time where like I was a voted spa
and the owner was there and he was
talking about all the bad reviews and I
was like I don't even know why I haven't
given you a good review yet I'm like I
love this place like it's it's a really
awesome experience and I can't think of
anything else that you could add to this
place that would create a more
meaningful experience but like it took
me talking to the owner to realize like
oh yeah like I need to give you some
props on on the social medias well I'm
talking to the owner right now the owner
of this podcast right Nicodemus and I'm
letting you know Ryan Nicodemus I can't
leave a review here but what I'm going
to do is review at least three podcasts
cool this week guys
I'm gonna go review your mom's house
podcast just because I love the name
yeah I'm gonna review your mom's house
Ryan okay Christina P is hilarious also
her husband Tom Segura is pretty funny
and they podcast together also the
cultural gap fest
there's one person on there who makes it
an outstanding listening experience for
me
her name is Julia Turner and and I
really enjoy that so I'm gonna go leave
reviews on those this week and I'll find
one other podcast probably Sam Harris's
podcast the wiki nut podcast is really
solid intellectually dense but they're a
bunch of podcasts I enjoy listening to
if you enjoy this podcast would you
consider giving us the gift of a review
and that gift is best given on Apple
podcast that's the platform most people
listen to so even if you're like me and
you listen to this podcast on on
overcast I that's where I listen my
podcast or maybe you listen to my feedly
or Spotify or somewhere else if you can
go over to Apple podcasts and just leave
us a review it does help because that
helps more people find out about our
show and you get positive reviews it
starts triggering the algorithms and it
puts us on recommended lists so other
people can find out how to live a
meaningful life and mostly with less
we're looking for honest reviews yeah no
don't fluff it up tell us how you really
feel yeah and I mean ultimately I'd love
for you to give us five stars but if you
hate the show first of
are you listening why are you still
subscribed but yeah we were obviously
not looking for a whole bunch of fluff
be honest be sincere take three minutes
leave us review we would really
appreciate it and we'll keep this
podcast 100% advertisement free our
first question today is from bale and
Phoenix I was just calling to ask about
gift-giving I know we've talked a lot
about you guys have talked a lot about
gift receiving but I'm just curious I
know that there's a lot of expectations
surrounding holidays and birthdays for
my family personally and it's a little
frustrating for me because I have
trouble finding gifts for my family and
friends that do add value to their lives
but they still kind of have this
expectation how would you go about
communicating that I could tell you with
with vexes birthday this past week I'll
go through that experience but I think
what Bale was looking for is like sort
of the easy answer here and for me if I
have to give if I feel compelled to give
a physical gift
it's all fun consumable it's not always
a consumable I'm not allergic to handing
out a physical gift yeah I guess what
I'm allergic to is the the idea of
obligation
yeah the obligatory guess I mean bales
question it kind of sounded like she
asked how do I tell my friends and
family I can't I'm not able to buy you
anything that adds value to your life
that is I would say that's the wrong
approach because there's certainly
something out there that can add value
to the lives maybe it is a consumable
maybe it's an experience right but
ultimately like if you really want to
add the most value with a gift ask your
friends and family what they want and if
maybe what you're saying there's like if
you what what you're saying Ryan is like
I don't know what's gonna add value to
your life maybe that means I don't know
you as well as I should know you and if
I can get to know you a little bit
better than I can figure out what would
add value to your life yeah and like if
you're asking a week before their
birthday that's too late like you need
to start digging into it a week after
their birthday for the following
birthday right and like start finding
out what you can get that is going to
add value their lives but like a few
things I wrote down is like you can cook
them a meal you can bake them a cake or
some cookies you can get it some rare
chocolate like they're what chocolate is
that that on Amazon that's like 20 bucks
a bar
my fruition yeah it's only nine or ten
now is it yeah anyway it's really good
it's like this I'll buy it like a couple
times a year put a link to that in the
show notes yeah yeah fruition so good so
like you could buy somewhere chocolate
um some kind of unique international
foods man someone sent us and I hope
they're listening right now
they sent us like some onion relish like
pickled onion relish from Scotland or
from Ireland or something it was out of
this world and I have not been able to
find it since but like what an amazing
gift like Mariah and I like it was
pretty much like onion jam too of Josh's
favorite things it was surprisingly
awesome though but I mean but but
getting something cool and unique like
that like I really appreciated that it
wasn't my birthday or anything they just
you know sent xavier fan but uh but yeah
go out of your way to do something
unique maybe that's another approach you
can take to one of the things that we
did this past week with vexes birthdays
we pretty much sell it was also it
coincided with Ella's Spring Break which
can be mind-numbing because like it's
the the trio of us just trying to
navigate LoZ interests oh we went to the
Natural History Museum we did that on
Becca's birthday itself so that was that
was one experience yeah yeah we had a
bunch of I mean we gifted a bunch of
experiences I didn't really give her
consumables but I also avoid obligation
or obligatory gifts on the day itself
because I think the better day and we
wrote about this in our in our book
essential there's an entire chapter on
gift-giving in there but I think the
better day to give someone a gift is
today yeah yeah it's it's not oh I'm
gonna wait until you March 28th or
December 25th or whatever the day is
because then there's an expectation and
so what we did is uh there was about two
weeks before that Beck set has been
shopping for a she was shopping on eBay
for this denim jacket the shoe and she
keeps getting outbid on anytime she's
like I find one I
I think I'll really enjoy that one it's
just you out bidding her every time
or we do with all of these like small
denim jackets they they look strange on
me but what what happened is eventually
she's like I'm tired of dealing with
this process on eBay
so can you take me to over to the Grove
to get a denim jacket and so I did that
it was several weeks before just because
she wanted to go and she found the
jacket she was looking for but while she
was there we were in the store she found
this really nice jacket it was like a
leather jacket that she wanted and it
was it was relatively expensive was more
than the denim jacket and so and she I
could tell she really liked it and but
we left because it was an expensive
jacket yeah and I went back there a few
days later and bought the jacket and
then like waited till the week of her
birthday but she was EXOR like little
jacket [ __ ] and so what I did was I I
bought the jacket but I didn't want to
give it to her on her birthday because
then he just feels like here is another
birthday gift and so what I did is I
went by Ella a gift as well and it's
like the Monday random Monday before
backs his birthday yeah I just gave Ella
this gift it was like a this puzzle that
you know she
I knew she would really enjoy and then
and I got her a card and I got Bex a
card and I got her that jack and they're
all wrapped up and they're just say in
the morning sitting out on the coffee
table yeah and actually it was the night
before they were sitting out on the
coffee table and so I gave also a
different gift here and I noticed this
with Ella she really appreciates it it's
the gift of anticipation it part of the
thing that's especially for kids is that
they don't know exactly what they're
getting it's the reason Christmas is so
sort of magical and mysterious is like
all of a sudden there's gifts under the
tree or or there's a tree there and
they're waiting for gifts to be put
under it and anticipation in and of
itself as a gift and I didn't have to
wait for her birthday to give her that
gift but or to even create the
anticipation you can give you another
example and she doesn't know about this
yeah but this episode won't be all about
in two days so this Thursday I've taken
her to the Ames house and I just told
her hey we have a surprise Thursday more
it's a gift and it's an experience but
it's not because there's a particular
day I think you would find value in this
I'm not gonna wait until your birthday
or for Valentine's Day or sweetest day
or Christmas or what are the other
holidays I'm not gonna wait for those
but that said we did want to celebrate
we wanted to celebrate her birthday so
her birthday week really so we did a
bunch of sort of experiences we went to
get ramen noodles a tattoo which Ella
really loves the gift of inclusion like
including Ella with these things makes
Ella happier but also that makes Bex
happier just see the idea of of us doing
things as a family we went out to look
at the super bloom I know you you did
that as well I didn't have to wait for
her birthday to do it but it was like
hey it's the week of your birthday and
so like we get to protract your birthday
in a way we took L to the beach which
actually ended up not working out
because it was 65 and 20 degree winds
and L was freezing we were freezing and
so we ended up just going to the pier in
Santa Monica and riding the roller
coaster and playing the fare games and
and all that stuff and it was a lot of
fun but those are often things we do
when it's not a birthday yeah I'd rather
create meaningful experiences
consistently than waiting for a time
when I'm obligated to do that yeah I
mean I agree and I disagree with you and
the reason being is is if someone wants
a gift on their birthday yeah like the
bird it's the birthday's about them yes
it's about their preferences right it's
about what they want it's making a day
setting aside something that you are you
are giving them exactly what they want
if someone wants a gift on their
birthday great I think it's a little bit
better to give it to him as a surprise
it's great to build that anticipation
it's great to to create meaningful
experiences but I guess I'm just saying
you know really when it comes to giving
gifts think about what that person wants
nah don't make it about well you know
I'm gonna give you this gift under under
my you know under my under my
preferences or you know what I don't
know the word I'm looking for there is
but but yeah with your with your family
with your friends Bale like of course
like yeah if there are some people out
there who have this expectation that
you're gonna give them gifts and if
that's the case great you want to do
that for them
you love them and you want to support
them and you want to support their
preferences just go out of your way to
find something meaningful and if you got
a probe a little bit then probe a little
bit to ask if there's there's no shame
in that
I totally agree and they're they're like
really considerate ways to probe people
right absolutely and also they're
considered ways for you to express your
preferences when it becomes your
birthday right and so I find that what's
important in this whole process what
we're both agreeing on here is hey let's
communicate effectively with the people
we love and if gift-giving is part of
that process Ryan you're right if
someone wants a gift I'm happy to get
them a gift as long as those are against
my values they're like if they're like
hey I want you to punch someone in the
face for my gift it's like well that's
that's right not a good idea right and
so as long as it's not against my values
and by the way gift-giving is not a
value it's simply a belief and I believe
that gift-giving can convey value
meaning added value I also don't think
it conveys love III think ultimately
maybe it's a step in that direction but
just gonna get you some shiny widget
doesn't mean I love you it means I could
afford to buy you a shiny widget real
love real respect is not transactional
like that it is transcendent yeah and I
think gift-giving can be part of that
process however I prefer if I'm giving a
gift to gift an experience you mentioned
several experiences we're gonna talk
about some other experiences and a
little bit or gift consumables like
coffee or food or apparently onion
relish they all I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book essential the sixth
chapter that book is an entire chapter
about gift-giving how Ryan and I give
gifts how we receive gifts how we turn
down gifts as well also one of my
favorite essays that we've ever written
in there is about love and the
commodification of love and I think
that's ultimately what we're trying to
avoid here of avoid is commodifying some
person commodifying an experience not
making it transactional so if you like
our podcast you'll really enjoy the
audiobook version of essential it's our
longest book I think it's a six hour
audio book or if you want the book book
or the e-book we'll be happy to send
those to you as well
what time is it well I was gonna add one
more thing uh as parents you can you can
actually set that expectation with your
kids so someone who likes presents on
their birthday someone who likes
presents on Christmas like that's
probably some kind of tradition or
something that they've been used to but
as parents like you can help your kids
appreciate gifts any day like you have
that ability to set those boundaries you
know what time it is Josh it's time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we are at the minimalists on facebook
and twitter and instagram learn in
lightning rounds for Ryan and I each do
our best answer every question with just
a short shareable lesson 140 character
response we also put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pith the answers
on social media if you like and now you
can find all of our pithy minimal
Maxim's in one place minimal Maxim's
calm thanks to our good friend Jessica
Lynn Williams
all right Josh Sarah wants to know what
do you recommend as a course of action
when it's considered rude to request a
specific gift or request that the person
not give a gift at all it seems like a
waste of time and resources to receive
gifts that you do not need or want but
you also do not want to hurt the gift
givers feelings well I certainly agree
with that you don't to hurt anyone's
feelings I think that's important too I
what what Sarah's doing here she's being
considerate like I I'm trying to
consider my friends and family my loved
ones and that's part of the
communicative process here in fact it's
part of expressing yourself as well and
so what Sarah is trying to do is she's
trying to get better at communicating
with her friends and family and loved
ones and she's trying to get better
expressing herself as well and it sounds
like she has the communication part down
it's easy to say don't buy me gifts
that's communicating something but
understanding the why behind it is
expressing yourself and so my pity
answer is a kind person is the best kind
of person well I see what you did there
and what I mean is you often when we
just say no no gifts there's there's
defensive what well yes it does and it
when you do this sort of parody of it
it's bah humbug
right that that's that's what people
often hear when you say no gifts people
were they hear bah humbug
I'm I'm uptight no that's not being kind
so instead of saying no gifts is I
really think the power of yes is so much
more powerful than no hear what I mean
by that instead of saying no gifts what
are you saying yes to what would you
like on your birthday and set instead of
saying don't ever get me anything I hate
when you buy me gifts
that's terrible they want to add value
to your life so instead of telling them
no what should they say yes to what are
the experiences you would get value from
and find ways to effectively communicate
that what's interesting
Sarah is if you have people in your life
who think is rude for you to request a
gift or for you to ask them not to give
a gift at all it's I mean it sounds to
me like if that's legitimately how it is
you've got people who aren't really
putting in a lot of thought with what
they're giving you anyway so you know
having them give you having having them
give you more effort when it comes to
gift giving you know there's nothing
that you can say that's gonna magically
make them want to give effort but what I
what I will say my short answer is it's
never rude to show someone respect so
even if someone does give you a gift
that you don't like and you've gone out
of your way to set the expectations
you've gone out of your way to to ask
for specific gifts or to to share your
preferences and someone still goes out
of their way to not respect your
preferences doesn't means you don't have
to respect them but yeah take the gift
say thank you and then go donate it I
mean that's the thing like when some
ultimately if someone is giving you a
gift they want you to have a meaningful
life and they want you to enjoy that
gift and if your life is gonna be better
without that gift well then if they
really want to see you live a meaningful
life they'll be perfectly fine with you
giving it away but regardless once they
give it to you it is yours you own it
you can do whatever you want with it
there's uh in that sixth chapter about
gift-giving here let me see if I could
find this Ryan because this is this
perfectly illustrates what you were
talking about talk for a second while I
find this well here it is here it is
okay so there was a question that
someone
in and this this essay is called letting
go of physical gifts the two of us tend
not to accept physical gifts often
sometimes it's hard to get people to
understand this cultural shift the best
way to approach the no gift getting
concept is to be proactive we set the
expectation with our friends and family
that we don't need any more stuff and if
we want to and if they want us to give
gifts they can get or they want to give
us gifts they can gift us experiences we
will enjoy they will celebrate our lives
with us by spending time with us not by
piling on more stuff of course most of
us don't want to piss people off we
don't want to offend people we worry
about what others will think and that is
exactly where Sarah is right now case in
point we received an interesting email
from a reader Dina about Joshua's essay
letting go of sentimental items and
here's what Dina says I recently started
my minimalist journey and up until now
everything I have let go of has been
pretty easy I just wanted to thank you
for this post because it helped me see
that we are not our stuff I now realize
that and I have to hold on to something
in order to remember a loved one their
memories are inside me however I'm
having trouble getting rid of gifts it's
not me who has a problem getting rid of
them it's the people who gave them to me
who might get a bit upset I was
wondering if you had any suggestions I
want to get rid of this stuff because I
feel like it is holding me up from
moving on with my new lifestyle but I do
not want to offend people and here was
my response to her in an email and then
I published it in this book with her
permission obviously most peers my
response most people won't notice or
they won't care a few might get offended
but that's okay
when I left my corporate job some people
got offended when I stopped checking
email every day some people got offended
when I said no to certain past
commitments some people got offended
when I untethered from negative
relationships some people got offended
we can't let these things bother us
though I think our friend Julian Smith
said it best yes it's really happening
right at this moment some
people don't like you and guess what
there's nothing you can do about it no
amount of coercion toting toadying or
pandering to their interests will help
in fact the opposite is often true the
more you stand for something the more
they respect you
whether it's grudgingly or not what
people truly respect is when you draw
the line and say I will go no further
hmm they may not like this behavior but
so what these people don't like you
anyway why should you attempt to please
them and then Ryan the essay goes on to
kind of just talk about yes we don't
want to offend people but if we're if
we're communicating effectively and
we're being kind and as you said Ryan
about it's never rude to show respect if
we're showing respect and they're still
offended well then you can say that you
know what I did my best that's what my
best foot forward it's time for me to
move on I totally agree ma'am all right
our next question is from Jennifer from
patreon what does a minimalist birthday
party look like that's a trick question
because there's no such thing minimalist
don't have birthday parties Ella we so
the here's another thing that we did for
Becca's birthday which we were kind of
pretending was Ella's birthday because
we wouldn't include her with stuff
taking her out to do the the pony rides
of Griffith Park and it's it's another
experience right and our banker he was
telling me the other day about how he
just like rented he wanted to do that
Griffith Park thing but his daughter was
too young so they rented a pony and but
they're like their house in Cheviot
Hills or something he's like I lived in
Texas my entire childhood I tried to get
away from this and now all of a sudden
my daughter's bringing it back in listen
I got a pony in my backyard right and so
ponies that's the answer I pick the
answer actually is the best gift is the
joy of less I think less when it's done
well is is joyous we can all think of
think of the over stimulated kids party
where they it creates anxiety in a way
whereas the best sort of kids party or
experience or whatever has the
appropriate amount but it
not over stimulating it's the
appropriate amount of stimulation so
true man I was walking down the street
over the weekend and there was a
birthday party going on I could tell his
birthday party is that happy birthday
signs and stuff dad like the parking
spots marked off for valet like you
couldn't park there you know during the
day or whatever like as I was walking by
here like you know bunch of people
talking you can tell it's a party not
there wasn't one person that looked
happy like it was like they all look
like yes we're here we're at the party I
mean you know I just caught one glimpse
of it so I can't say that's how the
whole party was but you know for
something so big and and with so many
people and so much decorations and you
got valet parking or guest cars it's
like you would think it would be this
you know it's total exciting party but
from what I saw it was not I mean it's
again it was only one glimpse I got and
that's not how a party is supposed to be
right all right my answer is this worry
less about how something looks worry
more about how it makes you feel so good
so you know Jennifer if you're wondering
how to throw a minimalist birthday party
I mean don't think about the decorations
don't think about you know the guest
list like think about the person who
you're throwing the birthday party for
what do they want and if they want some
decorations great if they don't want
decorations great but don't make it
about how it looks and make it more
about how the experience feels yeah and
if you want to make it aesthetically
pleasing it should be at the cost of the
experience right it it should not be a
form over function the function is most
important and then the form should
should follow that Ryan looks like we
have several more surprise questions
this week about donating unwanted gifts
what's the process for that about
children's birthday party expectations
and I know I know that's a big one
especially for people like me who have
young kids also about gift cards what to
do with gift cards should I get gift
cards also Ryan I want to talk to you
about what gifts you hate getting mm-hmm
and what gifts you get excited about are
there any gifts that you truly get
excited about I'm gonna talk about my
daughter Ella's odd but hilarious
birthday game that we played on Becca's
birthday oh my god like
I can't wait to share with you and we're
gonna play a round of underrated or
overrated where this is where Ryan I'm
going to come to you with just an
experience or a gift and you simply
gonna tell me it's overrated or
underrated and then we can argue about
it if we want to also I want to talk
about the 50 best experiences you can
give as a gift
that's 5-0 50 best experiences you can
give as a gift and if you want to hear
all that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I record an
entirely different long-form maximal
episode on the minimalists private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about stuff that we
don't usually talk about in public plus
patreon is the best way for us to fund
this podcast keep it 100% advertisement
free when you subscribe to the
minimalist private podcast on patreon
you'll receive a personal link so that
our maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also get access
to our entire back catalog of more than
100 private podcast episodes you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff including an additional private
podcast episode every week over at the
minimalists comm slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week being
informed is more important than ever so
I want to encourage people to read more
and get informed and now here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi my name is Candace and I'm
calling from Ottawa Canada and I have a
tip for the girl on your non line
podcast where she was talking about how
she liked candles
I am minimalist and also I live waste
free so what I do is I get a candle
without any packaging from you know I'm
really lucky because I have a friend who
makes them but you can probably get them
from any craft store and then let it
burn whenever you you when you like it
put the excess wax that falls off into a
mason jar and then when that candle is
done what I do is save all the wax and
microwave it and melt all the wax and
then get a new
Wyck from a craft store and the candle
is on forever so you never have to buy a
new candle and at the same time you're
you still get to enjoy the pleasures of
having candles and it's worked really
well saved me a ton of money and saved a
lot of plastic for the environment
my name is Scott Wood I live in Phoenix
Arizona I wanted to make a comment about
a lot of people who struggle with family
members who were not minimalist I'm new
to the minimalism process and how I got
my wife into it was to to discuss please
purchase a month ahead of time we have a
chalkboard it's actually chalkboard
paint on the wall and we write down the
purchases that we want to buy so if
we're walking through a grocery store or
we're walking through a mall which we
really don't do anymore but just for
example my wife says oh I really want
that book or I really want that blouse
or I say that we go ahead and we write
on the chocolate when we get home so
it's not a it's not an impulse purchase
and we wait to the end of the month and
the reason the waiter in a month is I'm
in sales my um my large commission check
comes in at the end of month and my wife
is themselves as well so we had the
means without going into debt without
using the credit card to purchase those
items I actually put your book on my
list at one point in time and had to
wait 30 days to get it so I could read
it but it takes away a lot of things so
I may put 7 items on there the first
month and by the end of month I only
bought one or two the next month I may
have three or four items the intimate
that may about one-third months I had
nothing on the list and I was kind of
disappointed but at the same time
there's a little bit of excitement
because what a good is that whittle down
my my impulse needs to buy and I started
looking at things differently my wife
who wasn't sure whether she wanted to be
involved in minimalism or my four kids
who also used in this system had begun
to see the the benefits of it we
discussed a lot of budget versus
happiness if you dip these things and
they give you temporary pleasure or a
spike of joy but then you get home and
you rip them open or you you use the
experience the book or you you play with
the item and 20 30 minutes sometimes a
week later the item is just untouched
again so now there
to be a lot more deliberate process in
which we buy things all right show real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist we're recording the
podcast right now and we love a gift
from you if you would be willing to hop
on over to Apple podcasts leave us a
honest review if you enjoy this show if
you get value from it we would get value
from your review and by the way it'll
expose it to more people we don't want
to beat you over the head with this
that's what we don't ask every single
episode a lot of podcasts I listen to
after their ads are done they're like
make sure you subscribe in review we ask
once or twice a year and so now's a good
time especially if you're a new listener
maybe you're a longtime listener you've
gotten value from it for a while you
know what just hop on over to Apple
podcast find the minimalist podcast
leave us an honest review we would
really appreciate it you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists com you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the minimus
if you're on our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
the minimalists comm you'll also receive
our simple Sunday emails each week for
our added value this week here is a gift
for you instead of a song this week
let's listen to my favorite scene from
season three of true detective it's my
favorite season so far Ryan have you
seen true detective yet I watched the
first couple episodes of season one and
okay what didn't get into it
I think season 1 is a masterpiece I
think so the guy who writes directs
created the show NIC NIC pizzolatto he I
mean it's all sort of self-contained
beautiful writing
and you remember season one like it was
sort of parodies of it like time is a
flat circle and all this stuff there's
some really beautiful gorgeous writing
but it's not as over wrought in the
third season it's more subtle and this
scene in particular it's a scene between
there's no spoilers here but my Hershel
ollie is the main character Stephen
Dorff Saul so Anna he's not in the same
Amercia Ali it's sort of three different
versions of him there's his 1980 self
his 1990 self in his 2015 self
interesting that it's sort of
interspersed throughout this this TV
show the series but
there's a scene in episode 3 the title
of the episode is called the big never
it's this two-minute scene between my
Hershel Ali's character Wayne and his
wife who is played by Carmen ejogo it is
man chilling I'll play it for you
right now actually all right show off
you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works enjoy the scene from season
3 of true detective thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time minimus